meat savor a ventilator manufactured
here in Doha this machine is equipped
with sensors to alert medical staff in
case the lung functions of a coronavirus
patient are deteriorating pneumonia is a
stage where ventilation becomes the
bridge between life and death for Qatari
officials this is a pivotal moment as a
country battles ghovat 19 the Emir
Sheikh Tamim bin Hamad Al Thani has
instructed the government to take all
necessary steps to contain the spread of
the virus a company affiliated with
qatar's Ministry of Defense teamed up
with the us-based laser and optics firm
their partnership produced savor His
Highness
chef named Muhammed Al Thani requested
the Ministry of Defence to source and
manufacture a ventilator and Burson
Holdings were tasked to execute this
project and as you can see you know in
the LA today we are in the very final
stages and we're starting in
manufacturing ventilators we plan on
manufacturing 10,000 units a month to
support Qatar majority of the components
are manufactured here in-house so from
raw material to manufacturing of the
components and some components are you
know obviously are sourced from outside
also Qatar and assembly takes place here
ventilators have become central in the
global fight against Kofi 19
manufacturers are ramping up output to
cope with the growing demands the
pandemic is showing no signs of slowing
down and many governments are desperate
to acquire ventilators to ease the
pressure on hospitals but officials here
say
Qatar won't face any shortages
and as the country steps up its war
against coronavirus it has sent to field
hospitals to Italy and shipped medical
supplies to China Iran and Algeria the
hope now is to produce more ventilators
to send all over the world as the
pandemic continues to spread hash Mara
al Jazeera